Chris what's your business it's tourism
business so when the Sun shines I got
business if the Sun doesn't shine I
don't so zeros control always shines New
York sure yeah always whenever there's a
cycle race there is well let me tell you
about our policy Chris then maybe you
come back and say how it might affect
you well our policy is this which is
that after 12 weeks an employee will
have a right to a regular contract not a
zero-hours contract based on the average
number of hours that they've done and if
the employee wants to carry on with a
zero-hours contract they can but we
think that should be in the hands of the
employee having the right to the regular
contract let me just explain why I say
that and I know this may be difficult
for your business but let me just
explain the reasons for that I don't
think we can base the future of our
economy on the idea and I meet lots of
people on zero-hours contracts that
people don't know from one day to the
next how many hours they're doing or
what wage they're going to be getting
because I did Mr Cameron was was honest
and I said the other day he couldn't
live on a zero-hours contract well nor
could i but if I can't live on it and he
can't live on there I don't we should
make the British people live on one all
right one elsewhere that in the creek
that's a good man